let's bring in Lara's brother now seb
casa lottie's said afternoon too first
of all how is Lara at the moment Laurens
doing very well at the moment she's very
positive and that she is just about to
start her second round of chemotherapy
and with each round of chemotherapy and
the lead becomes more urgent for us to
sign up more people and get everyone
around the world onto donor registry is
to help her as much as possible but
she's been absolutely overwhelmed with
the the lovely care and support and from
everyone around the world and it's been
really touching to see said we heard
there in the report that you it was
hoped that you might be a match and what
was it like for you both when you found
out that you weren't well obviously it
was it was very disappointing I mean any
sibling would love to be a match for
their sibling but that's what we've got
to realize is that the chances of
siblings being a match is only one and
four so it's something that everyone
would do for their loved one but you
can't most of the time and so that's why
we have to act as a global community of
people coming together and helping each
other by signing up onto registries and
doing something so easy as a stencil
trance law so tell me what's happening
there where you are today
well we're at the o2 center in finchley
road here today where we've got loads of
volunteers showing how popular lara is
as so many of her friends and family
friends have turned up to spread the
message of match for lara and sign
people on it only takes 15 minutes for
people to be registered on to the stem
cell donor registries and so we're just
grabbing people and spreading the
message because really this is it's an
awareness campaign it's something that
everyone would be happy to do it's just
making sure that people know about it
and people act quickly to help lara and
many other people around the world it's
called give a spit save a life as we can
see what exactly is it that people have
to do when they get there so they get
here they talk to our great team of
volunteers who will explain the process
they give a saliva sample and that will
be sent off for processing and that's
all it takes for them when they are if
they are eventually called up and to be
a stem cell donor and that is much for
most people very analogous to a blood
donation which is something that
everyone would do and is so so easy what
why do you think that there isn't the
register for this that there perhaps is
for for other things
uh well we do have this register that
has been built on the great work of
charities like Anthony Nolan delete like
cancer and the British bone marrow
registry and the amazing work that other
families have done when their loved ones
have been affected but this is just it's
an awareness issue and we just need to
keep doing campaigns like this to get as
many people knowing as possible and it's
amazingly helpful people can also tell
their friends especially they know
anyone mixed race or ethnic minorities
and to get signed up onto registries and
dispel the myth that stem cell bone
marrow transplants are a painful or
dangerous procedure because they're
really so routine and so simple Seb
thank you very much for talking to us I
bet there's lots of fingers crossed down
there today good luck and our best
wishes to Lara thank you very much thank
you